on july the 2nd a gas pipeline in the
gulf of mexico ruptured sparking this
fire
according to reuters it was the result
of damage from an electrical storm
and heavy rains in response a leading
democrat california's governor gavin
newsom
said this the ocean is literally on fire
but yeah
sure we can't afford climate action
could
there be a statement that is at one in
the same time as stupid
shallow cynical and false as that one
the ocean was not literally on fire the
gas that leaked from the pipeline was on
fire and it was put out and cleaned up
within five
hours it had nothing to do with climate
change it was an accident
so why did gavin newsom lie about it why
did he suggest that climate change was
the culprit and
climate action whatever he means by that
is the answer
because this is what democrats do they
lie about
climate all the time and to be clear
saying that is not denying the reality
of climate change
it's the democrats who are denying
climate change reality
in favor of a dark climate fantasy
the world is going to end in 12 years if
we don't address climate change
an existential threat to us as human
beings
the existential threat of climate change
is an existential threat
we have less than 12 years before there
will be irreparable damage done to this
country
the world is not going to end in 12
years or less than 12 years we are not
facing an existential threat there is
nothing in the science
that suggests human life on earth will
cease to exist climate change is real
climate catastrophism is demonstrably
false in 2014 the un's intergovernmental
panel on climate change
published what they called
representative concentration pathways
rcps for future global warming rcp
8.5 was the most extreme scenario and
became the basis
for the democrat doomsday chorus but
it's
wildly unrealistic for example it
assumes a
five-fold increase in coal burning
more than some estimates of total coal
reserves
in 2020 climate scientists in nature
magazine called out the catastrophism
they said stop using the worst case
scenario for climate warming
even david wallace wells who wrote a
book
called the uninhabitable earth now says
we're getting a clearer picture of
climate change and it's not as bad as it
once looked
he called on climate advocates to be
less alarmist
and yet the media complicit in the
democrats climate lies hype up every
single thing they can
to stoke the sense of impending doom
they call it a climate crisis
but they're manufacturing a climate of
crisis
concerns are growing the high
temperatures could cause more
devastating wildfires
we are in a historic drought here in the
west
the pacific northwest battles a climate
crisis an era of climate emergency but i
believe we are in a climate crisis this
is the last shot this country has to
deal with the climate crisis our last
shot where have we heard that before oh
right
15 years ago when al gore said we had 10
years left
they're no different to the people they
mock like evangelist
harold camping who predicted the end of
the world on september the 6th
1994 and when it didn't happen just
changed the date
the democrats climate cult takes a real
issue
and turns it into a fear-mongering
caricature
yes there is a drought but water
shortages
are a man-made problem in california
the reservoir system is designed for a
climate with frequent droughts
2019 was a wet year the reservoirs were
full
actually at 128 percent of average with
enough water
for five years but just two years later
they're telling us we have a water
shortage
that's not because of the climate it's
because of mismanagement
for years they've been flushing the
water out to the ocean
in a pointless bid to protect a species
of fish that has barely been seen for
decades
last year president trump predicted this
would happen and here we are
gavin newsom this week telling
californians
to cut their water use by 15
after he wasted 50
the left blamed climate change for
wildfires but wildfires ravaged the west
long before the recent rise in
temperatures last year around four
million acres burned in california the
democrats and the media said it was
proof
that climate change caused the wildfires
but before
european settlers arrived in the 19th
century more than 4 million acres burned
pretty much every year
although typically each individual fire
was smaller because the forests were
healthier not least thanks
to the stewardship of the native
population who actually understood
nature
unlike today's ludicrous lefty climate
cultists
who couldn't tell a healthy forest from
a pot plant
the actual causes of the devastating
wildfires sweeping the west
are devastatingly stupid democrat
policies
decades of fire suppression stopping the
natural burns that kept forests
diverse and healthy failure to remove
dead trees and brush
creating a catastrophic accumulation of
fuel hopeless
mismanagement of energy utilities
leading to more ignitions
from power lines inaction on one of the
causes of wildfires that's barely
mentioned by left-wing politicians and
their tv cheerleaders
arson if you actually wanted to do
something about water or wildfires there
are plenty of practical steps you could
take but no
all we get from democrats is pathetic
tweets blaming it all on
climate next they'll be blaming the
border crisis that they created on
climate oh wait they already did
why do they push these obvious climate
lies
because when it comes to climate the
democrats have adopted the tactic
of authoritarian tyrants through the
ages
manufacture a crisis to justify a
draconian
crackdown they know the facts don't
justify their extremist agenda closing
down the fossil fuel industry
banning the cars millions of americans
drive banning the way most of us cook
they want everything to run on
electricity
and where do they want that to come from
more solar power which can't be
economically stored
and how clean is solar anyway when the
panels are made with
coal and slave labor from china
they want more wind which is
intermittent unreliable kills up to half
a million birds a year
on top of that they want to shut down
nuclear power which is the most reliable
carbon-free source of energy we've got
and guess how these
climate leaders are filling the gap in
california
they're importing oil from saudi arabia
you can't make it up their entire energy
and environment policy is a giant
stinking slick
of idiocy and contradiction no to
american oil and gas
yes to saudi arabia's no to american
pipelines yes to putin's make us more
dependent on electricity
while making electricity less dependable
why aren't these democrats being laughed
off the stage
when they preach about climate they're
not the party of science they
deny science they deny science on the
pandemic on lockdowns on masks on
reopening schools
they deny science on two parent families
on kids and gender
on drug use and above all the democrats
deny
science on climate they blame climate
change for things that have nothing to
do with it
they push policies that wouldn't make a
difference to it and they block policies
like nuclear power that would help what
do they know about the environment
anyway the closest most of these people
have ever come to nature is dinner at
the rainforest cafe
what a massive opportunity for
conservatives
we know nature we love nature we want to
protect
and preserve and yes conserve nature
let's fight back against the democrats
climate lies
because they're not just lying about the
issue they're lying about republicans
and we can't let them get away with it
it was mike braun a republican senator
who just introduced legislation to help
farmers get paid
for sustainable practices it was ron
desantis a republican governor
who signed a 400 million land
conservation bill and it was donald
trump a republican president
who signed the most sweeping
conservation legislation in a generation
and whose pro-growth pro-innovation
pro-america policies
lowered our carbon emissions while the
sneering sanctimonious so-called
environmentalists in canada
saw theirs go up even with a carbon tax
pro conservation pro markets and
innovation
pro nuclear energy above all pro america
that's the climate revolution we need
and it's conservatives
who can lead it hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else